he's one of the greatest of all time and
that's one of the many reasons why uh
coca-cola zero sugar decided to reach
out to him to take part in the debate
the goatness campaign and courtesy of
that product joining us here on the rich
eisen show basketball hall of famer
julius irving how are you sir rich i'm
doing i'm doing very very good man so
nice to hear you boys same to you same
to you uh did you catch any of the
basketball action over the weekend dr j
i was there i was there man i was i was
i was over in the bleachers actually we
were in the coca-cola zero suite yes
okay
so what did you think of that game what
did you do
i'm sorry to say that because i know
again you're a philly uh you know guy
and i know villanova and kansas played
but i still can't get over what i saw
between carolina and duke
julius
yeah no that was that was just amazing
from start to finish
you can imagine these guys i mean they
go at it and they have such a history
and and when you look at the stats
historically it's like 50 and what at
least and um in coach k's career it's 50
wins and 49 losses it's
it's for the point differential is maybe
less than a hundred and a hundred games
and uh you know the rivalry lived up to
to the hype
for once right yeah
right i mean how many times does some
but you know you talk about something
and you look forward to it and it lives
up to it and it and it uh it um you know
surpasses your expectation level that
that truly was
something else um
so back in the day uh dr j how did you
get to umass
why and how how did that happen well it
was at the end of the day you know i did
visit some schools and visited iowa
state and that was as far west as i went
i went south for a minute and
you know i where did i go down there i
can't even remember but that was kind of
eliminated very quickly and then it kind
of came down to st john's at umass so
you know stay home in new york and go to
st john's
or
get away and you know two and a half
hours up the highway
and and go to umass and i i really fell
in love with the uh you know the big
campus atmosphere and
the whole college experience and just
kind of getting away with new york where
new york was always close enough because
new york was my home base
or whatever and i think i made the right
decision for me because coming out of
high school you know i did stretch up
the 6-4
by the time i graduated and i was about
165 pounds
and when i got to college you know i
grew a couple inches and gained weight
and that i was able to develop my
basketball game in a timely fashion
without being pushed without without it
being rushed
and uh and it had the staying power
of uh something that was developed
through time
uh instead of an overnight success story
so
that's how i got there and my
relationship between myself and my coach
jacqueline lehmann
stemmed from he and my high school coach
going to boston university together and
playing basketball at bu
together and you know sometimes
relationships are the best judge in
terms of making a decision like that
because you know
if you go with somebody who has
relationship with your guy or your
parent
or whatever you you're gonna be placed
in good hands and and uh it's more than
just you against the world i've got
julius irving basketball hall of famer
here on the rich eisen show i've i
i don't believe i've ever asked you this
question and uh you know i'm sure you've
been asked who's the first one to call
you dr j how did you get that nickname
well i i wasn't called dr j
actually until i
i became a pro
before that it was just the doctor
and
i had a buddy who i called the professor
and he called me the doctor and
and we we graduated high school together
we we went to the same college
and as a matter of fact i'm gonna play
golf with him this afternoon i'm gonna
play with the professor
so it's funny that you would ask that
question
uh when i got to
when i got to virginia
in my first year
uh as a rookie our trainer
you know he called
well everybody doc
so i had the nickname that he called the
team physician the doc he called and
wanted his other buddies to die so he
said well you got to be dr j
because we got too many doctors around
here so you're gonna be dr j and then
they started advertising
the virginia squires featuring charlie
the great scott and julius dr j irving
and that was the first time i ever saw
it written out
dr j
and uh there was no looking back after
that dr jay
so have you ever received like an
honorary doctorate in places where you
are legitimately dr jay julius irving i
have i have from uh from a temple
university
i have an honorary doctorate from there
and
i have two others
honorary i'm an honorary doctor i'm i'd
like to have a doctorate of humane
letters believe it or not
four times over huh
so
who was the who was the uh the best
player
when you arrived
and then when you left
basketball when you first got into the
aba who was the best player not not
named you
and then when you departed the nba who
was the best player let's start with the
the first one dr j yeah
so the first one when that when i got
into uh the aba
you know artists go more with the mvp
and the rookie of the year
so he went right to the head of the
class of course there was you know i
mean there were great players that
george mcginnis was was great david
thompson
uh you know he came backwards but um
but artist gilmore he was a force to be
reckoned with and how he's not in the
top 75
i mean that that question is the
legitimacy of the top 75
you don't have artist gilmore in there
he's the leading field vocalist in the
shoot in the history of the nba
and he was
he was just um
it hurts me because he's one of my aba
brothers
when i
left uh
well you know michael was michael was
surging
at the time because uh he came in three
years behind me so my first my last
three years were his first three years
so he was surging
but i would still give the nod to kareem
abdul-jabbar
you know that i left he he stayed and
played another year or another two years
after i left
and so it was probably gilmore on the
front end and abdul jabar on the back
end yeah kareem right i mean and and now
here we are lebron is
you know closing in right uh on the
all-time points record right now so
you know what what what is your thoughts
on lebron james and where he rests uh on
on the oil time
conversation the goatness if you will
yeah dr james the goatness
he's he's he's gonna he's gonna pass
everybody for one thing because you know
he comes in at 18 years old
and he was it was a pro he had the pro
body
and the pro ability as a high schooler
you know i i really haven't seen anybody
have that package moses most is probably
raw he's probably the closest guy
and it was bill willoughby who it didn't
work out for
and there were some other guys who grew
up kevin garnett you know but he's not
lebron and he's not moses
so
uh
so lebron is yes the chosen one in that
regard you know from
he's going to play into his 40s
and he's going to start at 18 and he's
going to have you know
he's probably going to have a
22-23 year career
and
and nobody's done that in basketball
either uh
because
those last few years for shaq and for
kobe
you know they were they were on the
bench they were on the sidelines they
were they were there they were getting
paid but they were on the sideline they
were done
uh
lebron it won't be
the same for him because he can still
be that complete player his skills are
so diverse and his
you know he's putting a million dollars
into his body every off season
to be able to still be out there with
the
with the tonal machine and and uh the
uh
you know stuff that legitimately
you know is going gonna help him
maintain his uh physicality
so yeah he's gonna be the guy at the at
the end of the day
he's gonna be the guy who
reestablishes the bar
for what the goat is
julia serving dr j here on the rich
eisen show courtesy of coca-cola zero
sugar and the debate the goatness
campaign uh one of the commercials for
it was you and joel embiid uh what do
you make of the sixers chances to bring
a championship
to philadelphia
for the first time since your days dr j
i think they're gonna surprise everybody
uh right now
you know they've been
played with some inconsistency in terms
of finishing games against teams that
they're supposed to beat
but i think they're going to surprise
everybody because somehow
the bench needs to get a wake-up call i
mean you can't play
play guys coming off the bench who
played for two quarters
and don't score
uh
so hopefully the protest is over
whatever the protest was
because that sounded like
a mutiny on the bounty
uh when i heard that i'm like
well something's wrong or we're gonna
get up there and get in that locker room
because these guys
you know they're getting paid and uh and
and they're
you know
they need to be productive for the team
to be successful you can just have a
great start i have no bench
so right now uh they need to fix that
and they got about a week or two to do
it well i mean doc's called him out
right i mean and
because the team's only you know a
couple games over 500 since hardin's
been there
do you think they can in fact kick it
into another gear
in in the playoffs doctor john i
hope so i hope so but i don't think it i
don't think it rests with the starters i
think it rests with the you know down
the line that you got to get eight guys
and you gotta get nine guys
out of the 12 and then if anybody gets
hurt it's the next man up and he's got
to be productive so
uh yeah you need you need some depth to
go deep
and it's not showing right now but maybe
they get lucky okay uh in your debate
the goatness campaign um one of the guys
who i would definitely debate is one of
the greats of all time
is moses malone you got a good story
when you could share with me
come on you know beaufort got first got
to philly
and he was used to riding around and
houston was top down and leave himself
in his car and he got the philly
he pulled it
and he left his dry cleaning in his car
and he came back out and the dry queen
and was gone right so he said when do i
see this guy wearing my clothes i'm
going to break his back
he had his shirts with the big collars
on them you know big flappy collars on
him he had some
bell bottom pads or something over there
and he was so hurt man he was like
and i said bro welcome to philly you
can't
this ain't houston you cannot do that
here
i just loved you know obviously his
all-time great uh quote of uh how many
times you know winning at fo fo and foe
were you around for that one were you
nearby it's locker or anything like that
you heard that
dr j
yeah but he was serious because he says
what did they say what is the
championship he said we got to go four
four and four you know beating
three to three series
but it came out like four four four
because you know he didn't really like
talking to the media and uh you know
he'd give him two minutes and then i
said he died i'm done
uh so he's very quick with his wit and
he's quick with his you know his puns
and
when he said four four four and we ended
up
you know playing 12 uh 13 games instead
of 12.
or whatever and that was history that
was that was a piece of history because
uh i think one of the groups in philly
you know made a song out of it
who could who could play with the you
guys today in today's game where you
know um
where you see somebody who's suiting up
today you know what that guy could have
played with me on the sixers or anything
like that you got
one well
if it was the other way around i'd take
andrew tony and then i'd sit him out
there and let him and steph curry shoot
those jumpers stepping over half court
because that that was and
andrew showed us that
in his game
you know lebron could play kevin garnett
could play i'm not kevin garnett kevin
uh durant
could play curry could play um
let's see uh what do you think of morant
dr j
what do you think of him
and tell me to play in any era
right he's
he's just amazing and then the big guys
i mean you know with uh jokic and embiid
and
[Music]
yeah go bear yeah go bear
for sure
oh they they would be good fits who's
your mvp for this year then before i let
you go on your day who'd you because
it's so close you know jokic had a great
weekend giannis had an incredible week
last week and embiid you know with
everything that happened with ben
simmons kept things on the straight and
narrow and the sixers are as you pointed
out earlier can uh can make a run what
do you think
i'm hopeful that
uh mb wins it
because you know because he does talk
about it and it's and there's something
that
you know it's one of those carrots out
there that he's reaching for
but i think the most deserving guy is
jokic
uh he hasn't missed any games
and you know night in the night out and
he's done it did better than he did last
year so he was mvp last year
and when you get better i don't think
you lose status
not if it's a fair if it's a fair fight
but i'm going to vote for nb because
he's my guy
and amanda cooper who knows how he's
going to finish up but both he and vote
convenient and it's cooper have missed
several weeks of play
joking just been out there every night
you know here's what he is well
everybody check out the uh debate the
goatness campaign it is the next chapter
of the best coke ever global campaign
from last year
and um
you know i appreciate the time with you
dr j always
good to talk to you say well absolutely
you too that's the all-time great julius
irving right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here